una marea rosada se extendió por el
Zócalo de Ciudad de México miles de
personas se movilizaron en contra de los
cambios electorales aceptados por el
congreso mexicano el miércoles la
reforma denominada como Plan B modifica
varias leyes que promueven una reducción
presupuestal del INE el Instituto
Nacional electoral pues esta es la
marcha donde cientos de miles en todo el
país representando a millones defendemos
nuestra democracia y refrendamos nuestra
confianza en el poder judicial para
echar para atrás el plan Beck según los
manifestantes las reformas ponen en
riesgo la democracia y favorecen al
partido oficialista Morena
hacen eco de la perspectiva del INE que
asegura que los cambios estipulados
debilitarían al organismo eliminando
cerca del 85% de su personal El clamor
principal en esta marcha es defender al
INE y con ello defender la transparencia
de las elecciones la perspectiva de
Andrés Manuel López Obrador es otra el
mandatario asegura que el INE respaldó
de su fraude en su contra durante sus
carreras presidenciales en 2006 y 2012
en las dos ocasiones salió como perdedor
habló ha defendido la reforma como
crucial para luchar contra su supuesta
corrupción y alegando que ahorraría 150
millones de dólares al año la ley ha
generado controversia sobre todo uno de
sus puntos que busca permitir la
transferencia de votos entre partidos
dentro de una misma coalición Aunque
este no fue aceptado por los
congresistas la oposición prometió
impugnar la reforma ante el tribunal
supremo